i remember went to a starbucks once in
like vegas and uh and i said i don't
remember what i [ __ ] ordered i was
like can i get a
mocha frappuccino or whatever the girl's
like
see that again and i'm like i thought
she didn't hear me
right so i was like yeah can i can i get
a mocha frappuccino and she's like
your accent's so nice i'm gonna have to
hear that one more time
i think i would die inside i'm just like
there's people like [ __ ] staring at
me i'm just like
i just want a [ __ ] marvel
so now every time i go to a starbucks
i'm so afraid of that so i just
don't know what are the mocha
frappuccinos yeah i was like no i just
do my best to do like an american accent
and they never [ __ ] question
americano please yeah i'm just like can
i get can i get a latte and they're
just like yeah okay which one do you
want you have a do you ever play up your
accent more in the us
oh [ __ ] turn that [ __ ] on like 100.
yeah sometimes i do
if i want to get out of the situation
yeah i just start [ __ ] talking like
bogan australian sometimes just so like
where it gets to the point where they
clearly don't understand what the [ __ ]
i'm saying and i'm just like all right
i'm out i'm out here do that do you ever
turn up your british accent
um i mean i go like full
[ __ ] downton abbey in america
sometimes because they [ __ ] eat it up
dude
like if i really want them to be nice to
me yeah like and like the the waiter
yeah
yeah i want good service yeah yeah oh
thank you so much that's amazing wow
wow thank you this food is delicious you
did a great job
oh my gosh and they're just like oh
my god i'm just not like such like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] though
i just it's fun it's fun man people are
so nice use it to your advantage man
i guess so yeah and then and then i
remember the americans would ask me
they're like
do you guys see american accents the way
that we see british accents and i'm like
no none at all not at all oh is it like
attractive
yeah yeah yeah yeah like they were like
because they were
i remember one time i the way i
explained it so i was like if
there's an american on public transport
everyone knows
everyone knows they know the loudest
yeah they know they know they hate it
yeah because we're so like like
everything we consume obviously it's
like american media we've seen
so much american stuff so we're so
desensitized to american media
and obviously to americans it's like oh
it's a flavor of british
is interesting very international i
think it's also because we've been to
america
so often now yeah four like conventions
because i remember back in
high school but i think even just
general british people aren't like
impressed by americans
accents i mean i remember back in
university whenever someone had an
american accent they would definitely
stand out maybe less so now because
there's more i think there's more
americans coming over to england to
study here yeah we had that like one
american exchange student in our high
school and
everybody [ __ ] loved it they were
like yeah like keep talking
yeah yeah yeah many things have changed
i don't know man at least in my
university
i mean i definitely i mean we're all
used to it but i think god and i
definitely used to because we live with
an american
yeah right i'm definitely used to it now
yeah
yeah before before then it was
definitely i i do think it was
more exotic before i because i remember
like american accent sounding so
harsh yeah like you could clearly hear
like the the hard
r like i mean yo what is that saying
i can cancel the heart r in every word
that has an r in it
not just a single word every word that
has an r in it
right because we don't pronounce the r's
in all of our words right so like when
we
when we hear the r in like in like the
sound right like i'm just like
oh god why stop please
i don't know hearing americans say
british swear words is like the most
disgusting yeah we've said that yeah
yeah we talked about [ __ ]
like uh like in a previous podcast but
like hearing sometimes
sydney would say wanker oh my god
there are some british words that should
never be said back yeah yeah wanker
wayne valencia i don't even want to hear
an american state bell end
belt i mean we don't even say that in
australia no and we have a bunch of
british ones you guys have australians
yeah but like
oh my god the first time i heard an
american say wanker i was like yeah
i was like oh speaking of like the most
the most
the one that i hear sometimes americans
say that i'm like please don't they're
like [ __ ]
i'm like yeah it's a [ __ ] don't say
have you ever had any like you know
because you both have american american
gf's right
have you ever had any like weird thing
like cultural difference that you've
like stumbled across you're like why why
do you do this
i mean i i didn't have it with aki but
like
you know as i mentioned earlier like my
first couple of like youtube friends
were americans right yeah and before
then i didn't really have like
international friends like all of my
friends were just aussies basically
um and so like when you speak a lot of
like especially in australian slang
right which is like pretty much a
different language in and of itself
in your head you're just like oh yeah
this is just a universal word that you
use
so i remember like saying a bunch of
slang to my like american youtuber
friends like
uh i don't know if you guys say like
arvo no that's australian
that's definitely australia it's too
uncivilized it's a peasant's language
i'm ironically passionate yeah so like
we say like you know instead of like
five in the afternoon we say five in the
other you're just cutting out stuff that
doesn't need to be cut out yeah like
it's
afternoon it's too long of a word just
say harvard it's never
that's got more than four letters no
thank you yeah and so i said like so you
know
obviously my american friends were like
you know what time is it in australia
right now and i'm just like oh it's like
three in the other and they're like
three in the arvo what's an arvo and i'm
like
oh my god they don't say ava so i was
like three in the
afternoon do you understand
and they're like oh yeah yeah yeah the
after do you understand do you
understand
are you youtuber it's been really funny
seeing how like when i first joined the
internet like
the british accent was like praised and
now it's just meme to [ __ ]
yeah everybody
because i think americans only thought
that like the the southern
uh you know yeah the porsche the porsche
southern accent and then they realized
that like 90
of the uk sounds disgusting like it
actually does like
my dad's from liverpool and when i like
go to go there
i i hate this i hate to hear it they
speak a different language over there
the more nor i'm gonna i'm gonna insult
the [ __ ] north now because i love the
north but some of the actions i
i i hate like some some of the the more
further north you go
the more i'm like up to scotland
the more i'm like man i i know we're
speaking the same language but for some
reason i cannot understand what we're
saying even though we're both apparently
speaking english right now yeah
i remember we were watching a tv show
with aki and it was like dudes from
yorkshire yeah and i was
out and you me and you having no problem
understanding yeah yeah and aki was like
is there
subtitles i i can't understand what
they're saying
i showed her like monty python's holy
grail yeah and she was like i need to
put subtitles on yeah
she's like i just like i literally don't
understand what his actions
are yeah and she was like no no it's
because it's an old movie and the audio
is bad i'm like
it's got nothing to do with the i can
hear it fine
it's crazy but what one thing i will
never [ __ ] understand i'm sure a lot
of americans will like
understand this but like when you say to
an american what is like
the sexiest accent like what is like an
accent that you want like people to like
whisper into your ear
yeah for some reason australian accent
is always
like the top and i'm just like what the
[ __ ] are you on about australian accents
are [ __ ] disgusting
australians like on like bottom three
it's like yeah it's like you're only
thinking australian actually because
you're thinking like chris hemsworth
right like
it's like yeah of course everyone wants
chris hemsworth to whisper into their
ears
of course but chris hemsworth is like
the point zero zero one percent of
australians
as as every british actor yeah right
anything like that and it's like it's
it's
like i think i saw like an article was
like the top three are like australian
british and irish
and that's what that's just pretty good
too scottish is like i understand
scottish and uh
irish yeah i think that's like kind of
cute i like scottish and irish yeah
scottish and irish are really really
nice
right but like i hear like the majority
of british accents and the australian
accent i'm just like nah
i can't i i grew up in the north and
like i was surrounded by those accents
yeah yeah and that's why i get i get
mocked when i go back they're like
you're not from here
yeah you you definitely don't sound like
the area that you're not no no and i
don't know if
that evolved over the time it did if you
go back to my
my very first youtube video i sound like
someone
from the area that i grew up oh yeah
when i first met you you had like quite
a heavy like welsh accent
yeah i wasn't even wow she was like more
northern but like because the the welsh
accent sounds like this you know
and i never sounded like that yeah but
everyone in my village talked like this
but you don't but you definitely didn't
sound like you do now no no i didn't i
sounded like more
just like general northern english yeah
yeah cause i've lost my accent quite a
bit people yeah yeah
when i look back at old videos i'm like
ew yeah yeah yeah
because because i was strong because you
like really iron out your like
you enunciate a lot more yeah i think
that's it's just the youtube accent
right where you have to
we have to like stop mumbling and start
paying attention to what you're saying
because
people from all different races are
going to be like listening to you yeah
because like because like the word
literally yeah i in australia would say
literally
yeah that sounds like yeah that's not
happening but i can't say literally
anymore i have to say
literally i don't know why and my dad
gave me so much [ __ ] for it the last
time i was home he's like
what the [ __ ] did you say literally you
sound like a [ __ ] american man
i was like say literally like a true
aussie i'm like all right
thank you for your patriotism dad i got
accused on one of the comments they were
like
connor isn't from wales connor no one
i'm from where connor is no one speaks
like that that's right yeah
and like it just didn't cross their mind
that like your accent can evolve
yeah exactly i think there was a study
that was uh done in antarctica where
they like sent
you know when they go to the scientists
go yeah and they wanted to see from all
these european scientists like what
would happen to the accents
right over like the three-month period
and it would fight like normally they
would all
for some reason pick up one person's
accent the most
right generally start to talk the way
they did yeah and i think that's
how it is like it can quickly change
your accent if you're surrounded by
people who sound
and i think that's why like i've lost my
accent a lot of the times because i have
spent like just from what i do i've
spent more time
yeah yeah i spent a lot with non-aussies
in london and then spent a ton of time
in japan a ton of time around america
yeah there's words like that i pick up
from like you know british english and
like right
right yeah it's just it kind of just
becomes like a conglomerate of just a
bunch of different languages
right it's just kind of mixture of like
internet language
as well on the internet so pretty much
yeah i'm sure if i moved back to england
my accent would like slowly develop
slowly back
uh slowly back into more of a bridge i
haven't noticed that when i go back to
australia and i talk to like my high
school friends or whatever
i just i just immediately kick into like
australia like i remember
uh when i met uh robert ninja or ross
yeah you know he's an aussie right
yeah yeah but he's been living in
america for so long that his natural
accent is just american now yeah but i
remember
the first time i met him at aex the
moment he heard my accent he was like
oh yeah man he's just [ __ ] like he
just completely changed to an aussie you
know it's just like
you could all you could talk like this
the entire time and i reckon like more
people would be like
into yeah yeah that happened to me when
i went back to wales i definitely like
regained some of my my my older accent
yeah
i don't like my old accent i prefer this
one i like to like speak clearly and
like
you know yeah like more concisely yeah
more of a voice acting accent
yeah it's more generalized and allows me
to say words
easy before i struggled with words
so you know